les chiffres le prouvent le covid 19
bougent encore mais l'arsenal pour le
combattre setoff la startup tour en gel
levaltech va lancer ses premiers essais
cliniques pour son vaccin nasal un
vaccin nasal dont on vous parler
régulièrement ici même cette fois les
choses sérieuses commencent 115
personnes vont tester ce vaccin spray ce
sera au premier semestre 2024 avec
l'appui de 5 hôpitaux français dont le
CHU de Tours l'espoir à terme et bien
c'est d'utiliser ce concept pour
d'autres maladies les précisions avec
les la Turquie
et on va pouvoir donc aller délivrer
donc dans dans le nez donc un premier
spray dans la première narine et la
deuxième dose dans la deuxième narine un
spray nasal comme vaccin du futur simple
rapide et indolore de pression suffisent
pour une dose vaccinale contre la
covid-19 l'intérêt c'est que ça va
bloquer le virus descendent entrée dans
le dans la cavité nasale et donc ça
protège contre les formes symptomatiques
de la maladie et l'autre avantage c'est
que ça empêche l'individu d'être
contagieux puisque le virus a pas le
temps de proliférer dans son organisme
un concept porté par la start-up
lovaltech dans les laboratoires de
l'Université de Tours points positif ce
vaccin nasal innovant se conserve à des
températures positives contrairement à
ces semblables injectés dans les muscles
autre intérêt le principe est adaptable
pour créer de futurs vaccins contre
d'autres maladies infectieuses le vaccin
covid va nous servir de preuve de
concept et pour être appliqué à d'autres
pathologie qui ne sont pas couvertes ou
mal couvertes par les vaccins actuels et
qui va pouvoir également anticiper les
futurs pandémies par exemple
récemment la start-up est élue lauréate
du programme France 2030 conséquence en
apport financier de 5,3 millions d'euros
répartis sur 3 ans de quoi anticiper la
production le contrôle qualité du vaccin
et aussi la suite des événements
aujourd'hui lovaltech est en capacité de
pouvoir très prochainement début 2024
faire les premiers essais cliniques chez
des volontaires qui vont donc tester
l'efficacité de ce vaccin qui
aujourd'hui le seul au monde à être
efficace quel que soit les variants
actuels et futures des essais cliniques
sur l'homme menaient à grande échelle
dans plusieurs hôpitaux de France et
pilotés par le CHU Bretonneau de Tours
lovaltech espère une mise sur le marché
de son vaccin nasal d'ici 2 à 3 ans